der scheinbar zurückhaltende von der
damals schon mächtigen Seitenlinie tritt
im dezember 2021 in die erste Reihe vor
allem für seine twittergemeinde eine Art
Held für Olaf Scholz geht angeblich an
Karl Lauterbach kein Weg vorbei
für mich ist ganz wichtig dass wir dann
natürlich auch im Blick haben dass die
Pandemie noch lange nicht vorbei ist und
deshalb haben sich anders kann man das
gar nicht sagen bestimmt die meisten
Bürgern und Bürger dieses Landes
gewünscht dass der nächste
Gesundheitsminister vom Fach ist das
wirklich gut kann und dass er Karl
Lauterbach heißt er wird es der Mann vom
Fach er verspricht wissenschaftliche
Ordnung in die corona-lage zu bringen zu
diesem Zeitpunkt hat der künftige
Minister schon einen schweren Fehler
gemacht im August 2021 spricht der noch
nicht Minister von einer
nebenwirkungsfreien Impfung aus
medizinischer Sicht ist das Unsinn alte
Mediziner Regel was wirkt hat auch
Nebenwirkungen nur ein missglückter
Tweet sagt Lauterbach heute auch das
stimmt nicht etwas eingeschränkt
bekräftigt er seine Aussage Impfungen
sind hat mehr oder weniger nebenwir frei
das muss immer wieder gesagt werden das
ist also das sind die Leute die sich
jetzt nicht impfen lassen wollen das
sind ja auch zum Teil Opfer der
schäbigen disinformationen in den
sozialen Medien gewesen es ist
Lauterbachs Kommunikationsstrategie den
Zweifel viele wegzuwischen damit ist er
nicht allein geimpft gewesen oder
gestorben es handelt sich um eine
Pandemie der ungift meine Damen und
Herren die Devise lautet impfen impfen
impfen denn wir momentan erleben wir ja
wirklich eine Tyrannei der ungeimpften
betrachtet uns als eure
Versuchskaninchen und jetzt macht es es
ist zu eurem besten vor einer Woche nun
spricht der Bundesgesundheitsminister
von sehr seltenen schweren Impfschäden
jedes Schicksal Tour im Leid
Quere Impfschäden sind auf der Grundlage
der Daten des paul-ehrlich-institutes
oder der europäischen Zulassungsbehörde
in der Größenordnung von weniger als 1
zu 10.000 Impfungen das zitierte paul
Ehrlich Institut eine Behörde des
Bundesgesundheitsministeriums dagegen
erfasst gar keine im Schäden
im Schäden ist eine ganz andere Sache da
geht es auch um wirtschaftliche und
gesundheitliche Folgen von
Nebenwirkungen die über das Normalmaß
hinausgehen das ist keine Beurteilung
die das volljährlichen Institut vornimmt
Widersprüche sind Wasser auf die Mühlen
der Impfgegner und Skeptiker plötzlich
gibt es Raum für ihre Zweifel für ihre
Ängste vor Impfschäden Raum den es in
der Pandemie gesellschaftlich politisch
und medial nahezu nicht gab später
Einsicht
mir ist es für mein Land ein
ausgesprochenes Anliegen dass davon
betroffene den Eindruck haben dass ihr
Probleme ernst genommen werden und dass
sie eben auch nicht das Gefühl haben
weil der Staat sehr fürs impfen geworden
hat
ignoriert er jetzt diese Fälle das kann
man nicht das können die Länder auch
nicht im Fall von Impfschäden haften sie
und nicht die Impfstoffhersteller das
hat die EU-Kommission damals unter Druck
ausgehandelt 18 Millionen Menschen in
Deutschland haben sich bis heute nicht
impfen lassen vor allem die zwei
g-politik Zutritt nur für geimpfte und
genießene hat zu einer in der
Bundesrepublik beispiellosen Ausgrenzung
von ungeimpften geführt eine Impfpflicht
gibt es bis heute nicht der Druck auf
nicht geimpft auf diejenigen die
wirklich Angst hatten bevor sie immer zu
lassen ein Teil von denen hat ihren
Beruf verloren ich erinnere mich an
Sportler die erklärt haben dass sie
große Bedenken haben sie für sich
entschieden haben
Kimmich beispielsweise was war das für
ein unglaubliche soziale Druck der
ausgewürde entsprach die bisweilen
einseitige Informationspolitik der
Regierung dem Leitbild aufgeklärter
Bürgerinnen und Bürger
ich würde sagen dass man nicht voll
umfassend informiert hat und das ist
natürlich schon Aufgabe aus der Politik
dass man hier sagt großes der Vorteil
was ist auch der mögliche Nachteil das
gehört zur aufrechten Politik dazu ohne
dass man irgendwie das beeinflussen will
der Zweifel nagt an Abgeordneten im
Namen der Pandemie verfiel Politik in
den erziehungsmodus aufgearbeitet ist
das nicht geschweige denn geheilt
und aus Aachen ist mir jetzt jemand
zugeschaltet der während der Hochphase
der Pandemie gleich mehrere
entscheidende Funktionen Inhalt inner
hatte er war CDU-Vorsitzender
Kanzlerkandidat und NRW
Ministerpräsident und damit auch Teil
des höchsten Entscheidungsgremiums von
Bund und Ländern einen schönen guten
Abend
guten Abend
ich frag mal ganz direkt auf den Kopf zu
hätten sie und ihre Amtskollegen damals
in der Pandemie mehr auf das Risiko von
Impfschäden hinweisen müssen
wir haben diese Frage ja immer wieder
erörtert mit unterschiedlichen
Wissenschaftlern und Experten erörtert
und ich glaube im Nachhinein hätte man
auch sagen müssen offen klar es gibt
auch Nebenwirkungen und Nebenwirkungen
völlig zu bestreiten das war jedenfalls
nie die Position der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz aber man
hat es nicht gesagt man hat es nicht
kommuniziert und das hat gerade
Leugnern
Verschwörungstheoretikern Raum gegeben
weil jeder weiß dass es bei jeder
Impfung auch Nebenwirkungen geben kann
deshalb die Kritik am
Kommunikationsmanagement die ist
berechtigt und Sie haben gerade eben in
ihrem Beitrag wieder ein Beispiel
gesehen Herr Lauterbach verweist auf das
paul Ehrlich Institut
bei den Zahlen die gemessen werden mit
Impfschäden und das paul Ehrlich
Institut sagt wir müssen es gar nicht
das ist alles nichts was Vertrauen
schafft und ich glaube daraus müssen wir
lernen
diese Widersprüche sind genau das
worüber ich gerne mit ihnen reden möchte
sie sagen es ist nicht richtig
kommuniziert worden es hätte aber auch
noch zusätzliche Methoden gegeben von
denen auch keinen Gebrauch gemacht wurde
es gibt zum Beispiel bis heute keine
flächendeckende systematische Erfassung
von Impfschäden die gibt es nur
vereinzelt Baden-Württemberg bemüht sich
da um eine bessere Ausleuchtung das
Problems auch sie haben als
Ministerpräsidentin Nordrhein-Westfalen
kein solches Programm gestartet warum
nicht
ja ich war ja bis
oktoberministerpräsident inzwischen ist
über anderthalb Jahre vergangen zu
dieser Zeit hatten wir wenig Signale
über Impfschäden aber in der Tat sie
haben Recht da muss die Politik jetzt
auch eine kritische Bilanz ziehen denn
es können immer wieder Pandemien kommen
und wir müssen uns vornehmen demnächst
anders zu agieren bei den Impfschäden
ist das offenkundig aber das betrifft
auch viele viele andere Maßnahmen ich
persönlich zum Beispiel würde es
schätzen wenn wir eine onkel-kommission
im Deutschen Bundestag einsetzen würden
die alle Fehler alle Schäden dieser
Pandemie Politik einmal untersuchen
würde um es beim nächsten Mal besser zu
machen damit wir nicht wieder in eine
solche schwarz-weiß-republik verfallen
entweder du bist dafür oder du bist ein
corona-leugner nein es gab
wissenschaftliche stimmen die nicht
gehört wurden die vereinzelnden
Maßnahmen auch gewarnt haben und unsere
Diskussionskultur muss in Zukunft da
besser werden das ist eine Lehre die ich
aus der gesamten Pandemie ziehen jetzt
das war eine schwarz-weißmalerei würden
Sie rückblickend sagen dass es nicht
richtig war Menschen die sich nicht
impfen lassen wollten auch Sorgen von
jedem Wirkungen mit zweijährigen zum
Beispiel so unter Druck zu setzen wie
man es getan hat
also es gab ja sogar die Vorschläge
einer Impfpflicht übrigens
parteiübergreifend das was wir hier
erörtern ist keine parteibolitische
Frage ich war immer selbst sehr sehr
skeptisch bei einer Impfpflicht ich war
auch bei 2G skeptisch das ist erst
später eingeführt worden aber sie haben
weil es quasi Menschen das ja ich war
damals ich war dann
Bundestagsabgeordneter weil es Menschen
aus dem öffentlichen Raum ja verdrängt
hat wenn sie er sich einmal vorstellen
was in diesen Verordnungen drin stand da
stand drin Wochenmärkte Weihnachtsmärkte
Freizeiteinrichtungen
Sportveranstaltungen Karneval ich weiß
übrigens gar nicht wer das überhaupt
überprüft hat all diese Veranstaltung
jeweils einen Impfnachweis zu
kontrollieren also man hat da vieles
gemacht aus Aktionismus mit dem guten
Ziel möglichst viele Menschen zum Impfen
zu bringen aber man hat auch manches
außer Kraft gesetzt die damalige
Bundesjustizministerin Frau Lambrecht
hat damals gesagt wir Regeln genau wann
jemand seine Freiheit zurück bekommt
in der Pandemie auch Gegendruck auf
ungeimpfte ausgesprochen sie haben aber
auch bei ihren Parteikolleginnen beim
Bundesgesundheitsminister sparen und war
Angela Merkel damals kein Gehör gefunden
warum das denn nicht
ja dann müssen Sie die Fragen ich habe
meine Position immer deutlich gemacht
das wurde zuweilen als lockerer
beschrieben während andere möglichst
alles verbieten wollten und sehr harte
Maßnahmen wollten da haben wir unter dem
Ministerpräsidentin gerungen aber in der
Tat ich habe es ja eben schon gesagt es
ist keine parteipolitische Frage Frau
lambericht war die zuständige
Justizministerin die über Grundrecht in
dieser Weise geredet hat von Jens Spahn
weiß ich dass er immer gegen eine
Impfpflicht war und am Ende ist sie ja
dann auch nicht gekommen aber der Druck
auf die ungeimpften den hat es gegeben
und deshalb finde ich ist der Staat
jetzt auch in der Pflicht denen
beizustehen die diese im Schäden
erlitten haben ich selbst hatte ein
Stiftungsmodell für richtig wo auch die
Konzerne wie Bayern Tag oder moderner
oder andere die viel Geld verdient haben
in der Pandemie freiwillig ihren Beitrag
leisten die Haftung hat man ja
ausgeschlossen bei den Verträgen
aber ich finde hier besteht eine
moralische Pflicht ähnlich wie beim
Staat die wenigen das sind ja nicht
viele die jetzt im schämen erlitten
haben auch zu entschädigen ein Plädoyer
für Fehler Aufarbeitung und
Unterstützung von Armin Laschet
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch